hi i'm corey casper i'm the chief
executive officer of the infectious
disease research institute in seattle
washington and i'm a professor of
medicine and global health at the
university of washington
also here in seattle today what i'd like
to tell you about
are technologies that we're developing
here for accessible
durable and broadly protective vaccines
against coronavirus but
technologies that are also applicable to
other pandemic infections in the future
by way of background i'm a physician
scientist trained in infectious disease
i've been working on viral infections
the prevention and treatment of these
for over 25 years i'm excited to present
to you these technologies today that i
think
really could be transformative in ending
this pandemic
so by way of agenda i'll first start by
talking about the current state of
vaccines
for covid i'll talk a little bit about
the gaps that exist right now
in existing covet 19 vaccines as i see
them
and then i'll talk about some of the
exciting technologies that we are
developing here to address these vaccine
gaps
and specifically i want to talk about
technology that we're developing
to make vaccines stable at room
temperature
for many many months which will help to
improve access
technologies that will lead to more
durable vaccine
responses technology that will
allow for a broad protection against
multiple
viral strains as they evolve or mutate
and finally talk about something that is
not quite a vaccine but a novel therapy
that we're working on here
in the treatment of covid19 so with all
that let's get into our presentation
today
what i want to start with is our view of
the current covid19 vaccine landscape
and so as many people probably know
there have been
close to 270 vaccines for covid
that have been pursued or developed by
researchers around the world
that funnels down pretty significantly
when you go from those that are in
pre-clinical studies
to those that are in approved or
emergency approved
indications when you look at the list
though of those that are actually
available to be put into people's arms
as of today
you get the list that is here and that
list that you see
is of essentially seven different
vaccine
candidates they're summarized here and i
won't go into all of them
into any specific details because that's
beyond the purview of this presentation
today
but what i would like to address is
where i see some of the gaps in these
vaccines
so right now there's a couple of things
that i've highlighted
in this table that show where i think we
still have
some miles to go in terms of our ideal
vaccine for covit 19 and for future
pandemics
first you can see the two rna vaccines
these are really some of the lead
vaccine candidates
here in the united states they include
the pfizer and the modernity vaccines
these are mrna vaccines that are
delivered in a
butterball or a fat particle known as a
lipid nanoparticle
these vaccines have a two dose schedule
typically several weeks apart
and they are distinguished from each
other by certainly the pfizer vaccine
being
needed to be stored at deep cold
temperatures minus 20 degrees celsius
but they're also distinguished by the
fact that they're both close to 95
effective on the other hand there are
other
technologies apart from rna that are
also in vaccines that you can get around
the world
most notably here in the united states
are the johnson and johnson vaccines
these vaccines are based on a human
adenovirus platform and they're notable
for
single dose regimens the need for less
deep colds which is simple refrigeration
as for storage
and an efficacy that may not be as high
as the rna vaccines but certainly an
efficacy that would be enviable
for a seasonal flu vaccine the rest of
the list you can see is rounded out by
candidates which are
much more widely available in the rest
of the world these include vaccines that
are based on adenovirus
platforms and inactivated viruses the
distinguishing characteristics of these
vaccines are that many have multiple
dose regimens
many of them are required to have deep
cold storage
and at least two of them have efficacy
numbers which
are lower than has been reported
certainly for the rna vaccines
that we're using around the world so
taken together
where i think we still have some gaps
are in three
key areas these three key areas are in
access durability and breadth
in terms of access as i've mentioned in
the previous slide the requirement to
keep vaccines deeply cold
and even at refrigerated temperatures
put them out of reach
for many people around the world here in
the united states we often think that
that doesn't apply to us
that you know keeping a vaccine cold
shouldn't be an issue
but i'll show you in subsequent slides
it is an issue here in the united states
and i believe
continue to be as well as in places
where resources are extremely limited
and the cold chain is very fragile
on top of that we have issues of
durability so i'll show you some data
later in the presentation to show you
how long we model the current rna
vaccines
will protect individuals and there are
limits to that right now the current
guidance from the federal government in
the united states is that
the durability of protection is likely
about six months
could be longer but that's right now
what we're willing to say
that could be a problem for a virus that
shows many signs of becoming endemic
finally we have issues with breadth so
really anyone who's watching the news
today is constantly seeing messages
about these vaccine these viral variants
which
may reduce the efficacy of some of the
vaccines
that are currently being used and so we
really need vaccines that will address
all three of these issues access
durability and breadth
and the good news is that i think we
have technology now that can
can do just that so going into
a little bit more detail about access so
there have been
significant acts challenges to access
here in the united states
and that has been most uh represented by
what we're calling vaccine wastage so
what we know is that there's close to
100
000 doses of covid vaccines that have
been wasted within the first several
months of rollout
here in the united states despite the
fact that most people in this country
still cannot access a coven vaccine if
they want it
here on the right you can see some of
the press clippings but
as you know when a vaccine is brought to
a vaccination center and we have many of
these mass vaccination centers that have
sprung up
around around the united states when a
vaccine is brought to those centers
it must be used immediately when it is
thawed it can't be restored and so what
that means is that there is this rush
to use these vaccines that have been
brought to the vaccination centers and
if individuals don't show up for their
vaccines
it means that those doses get wasted so
here in the united states that's been a
significant problem
and one that's not getting a lot of
attention because we don't routinely
track the number of vaccines that are
wasted or have to be discarded
around the rest of the world though this
is an even greater problem so
in one study that was done a few years
ago it was estimated that 72 percent of
clinics in africa have
unreliable access to electricity oh half
of freeze-dried and
25 of liquid vaccines these are just
have to be stored under simple
refrigeration
are wasted um due to um due to
challenges in maintaining this cold
chain and deep cold chains are really
infusible
in regions where billions of people on
this globe live
there's some photographs on the right on
the top right you'll see
measles vaccines being delivered on
coolers
here on the backs of bikes
uh in the democratic republic of congo
and you can see that that is a real
challenge
and the uh slide below that the picture
below that is a
medicine freezer in nairobi uh a picture
that i took a few years ago
showing that even within these freezers
um
there are often are challenges due to
the constant electricity surges
in maintaining these cold temperatures
and with the frosting in the fridges
so really we need a solution that will
bring a vaccine that is stable at room
temperature
to get the billions of people on this
planet protected against
sars cov2 there are
important things that we need to think
about in terms of durability so in terms
of durability
we don't know the current duration of
protection the current recommendations
as i said are that these vaccines may be
protective for
six months but what we do know
and i'll show you some of these data
later are that um
that the levels of antibody titers
especially neutralizing antibodies which
we think are probably one of the better
correlates of protection
to many of our vaccines wane and so
we know that they exceed levels of
convalescent plasma for three months
but beyond that we're not sure so
based on some of the modeling data i'll
show you later we have reasons to be
concerned that the current vaccines that
we have
will not be durable certainly for more
than a year
and beyond that may require constant
boosting or
annual revaccination and given the
challenges that we've had even just with
a single
dose roll out it would be much more
ideal if we had a coveted vaccine
that could be durable for for decades
going to the next slide we also um
uh so so this these are data that as i
mentioned suggest
that um that the sars cov2 could be some
become rather than a seasonal
respiratory virus an endemic one so
we've already seen the virus
persist over two respiratory virus
seasons
and again there are many experts who
think that these pandemic coronaviruses
will circulate
for long periods of time the other
reason that i think we need to be
concerned is that we know that the level
of antibodies that we need to remain
protected against these viral variants
is higher and that if antibody titers
wane
from when you first become vaccinated
those waning titers may expose you
to greater risk from the viral variants
than even to the wild type and so the
vaccine could be even less durable
against variants should they emerge
the the final important feature that
we'll talk
about today that i think represents an
unmet need in current vaccines are the
breadth of protection
so i just mentioned the viral variants
and the
good news is that data suggests that all
the current vaccines
that are available in the united states
retain efficacy
against the coronaviruses that are of
different strains from the ones that
we're seeing here whether it's the uk
the south african brazilian variants and
so what you can see here is that on the
slide on the right
that these vaccines do retain some
efficacy against the viral variants but
that it is reduced
and that again does the combination of
reduced efficacy against the viral
variants
plus weaning antibody titers with the
time since vaccination
do those two factors together leave
people particularly vulnerable
as the as the epidemic
persists and progresses so with all of
this this hasn't been
bright cheery news and so rather what
i'd like to do is now turn to
what we think are tractable solutions
that could exist today
and be useful for protecting individuals
against covid19
and it's the severe effects of that
clinical disease
so the first technology that i'll talk
about is our thermostable rna
vaccines and the second technology that
i'll talk about are our vaccine
adjuvants so let me start with our
thermostable rna vaccine
so this is a table that i put together
that addresses what i think are the gaps
in current rna vaccines many of which
i've already spoken about but this goes
into it in more detail
and more than that how idris rna
vaccines address these current
limitations
so first on the left we've talked about
storage and distribution
and the need for the deep cold chain for
at least one of the two rna vaccines
so what we'll talk about today is that
our rna vaccines
are delivered with a novel delivery
vehicle that we call a nanostructured
lipid carrier
this nanostructured lipid carrier allows
the
vaccine to be biophilized or
freeze-dried and in so doing
it allows it to have up to one year of
stability at room temperature which we
think is a major advance
next in terms of potency our rna
platform is what we call
self-amplifying and self-adjuvanting
these two factors mean that we get
antibody titers after the first dose
that are higher
than after a multi-dose prime boost
regimen
so we think that the potency of these
vaccines may also be greater
with that greater potency we think we'll
have a greater duration of immunity
because it will take longer for the
antibody titers to fall
and finally we will have a very
adaptable platform and the reason for
that is that our
platform has advantages in terms of how
it's manufactured
that make it much more suitable to viral
variants and in that i'll tell you my
story about jelly donuts so with that
on the next slide we see um the the
basic design of our rna platform
is an alpha virus rna replicon based on
the
venezuelan equine encephalitis virus and
what we do is we knock out the
structural proteins from that alpha
virus
and replace them with the genes that
we're interested in to put into our
into our vaccine the this alpha virus
is delivered into the cell effectively
by our nanostructured lipid carrier
and once it's in the cell in the
cytoplasm it undergoes
a limited number of cycles of
replication so this is different than
mrna vaccines and in those 10 or 12
cycles of replication that the virus
goes through
it amplifies the target proteins at the
same time
the nanostructured lipid carrier
contains an adjuvant and that adjuvant
leads to more potent vaccine responses
so this is novel technology but what's
even equally as
novel is the way we deliver it so i want
to tell you about my tale of two donuts
i find when i talk about the story this
way most people
love and know donuts and so this really
resonates with folks
so the current vaccines um the moderna
and the pfizer biontech vaccines are
delivered by
this lipid nanoparticle and to me that
is like a jelly doughnut
so what your what you have is your
flavor of the doughnut in this case a
raspberry doughnut the raspberry
represents the strain of the virus
you're trying to
protect against so the raspberry in this
example
is the wild-type version of sars-ko v2
and the donut is the fat ball
the lipid nanoparticle that delivers it
to the cell what this means is that
every time you make this vaccine
you have to put the rna that you're
interested in
inside the the fat ball the lipid
nanoparticle and manufacture it in total
each time you want to have a vaccine
ready
on the other hand ours you can think of
more like a glazed donut that has
sprinkles on it
so in our case we can make billions of
glazed donuts
keep them in simple storage and
stockpile them
and then each time there is a new viral
variant or
a a new pandemic we simply change the
sprinkles so instead of rainbow
sprinkles we may use chocolate sprinkles
or we may use vanilla sprinkles
and that gives us incredible flexibility
to not have to re-manufacture the entire
vaccine platform
each time there's a new viral variant or
each time there's a new strain
it also means that we can vaccinate in a
multivalent fashion much like our
seasonal
influenza vaccine contains three or four
different strains that are circulating
we can decorate three or four
different strains on to the surface of
our donut
and protect against multiple coronavirus
strains
so in more technical terms the
comparison between the two delivery
vehicles is shown here
on the left you see that the rna is
shoved inside the lipid nanoparticle on
the right you see our nanostructured
lipid carriers
they our nlcs have enhanced stability
and they're as i'll show you on the next
slide are delivered more efficiently
into the cell
they have the rna decorated on the
outside and yet even though it's on the
outside it remains stable at room
temperature for a year
it's attracted to this butter ball by uh
electrostatic charges so the rna is
negatively charged and the phosphate
groups
are positively charged and this means
that we can stockpile the nanostructured
lipid carrier
and quickly manufacture the rna to suit
and this means that we're both scalable
and widely
ready for the next pandemic and then
within that core
of this butterball is a lipid core
but that includes squalene which many of
you may know
is used currently as a vaccine adjuvant
for many different types of vaccines but
is a potent vaccine adjuvant that we
think
adds potency to this platform the data
which are pre-published on bioarchives
and you can see them here
undergoing review and a peer-reviewed
journal show that
really the experiments on the left show
that the
vaccine construct
resists rna degradation uh with rna's
challenge
for up to eight months at room
temperature and up to two years at
uh at four degrees c and that room
temperature is 25 degrees celsius and
the graph that's next to
in the middle here it shows the biologic
activity
of the vaccine looking at protein
expression
after it has been kept at room
temperature or refrigerated temperatures
refrigerated a simple refrigeration for
21 months room temperature on the
counter for eight months
so it really retains activity just like
the freshly made vaccine
and then one of the things that we think
is adding to the potency is on the graph
on the right
you can see that generally we get about
one log
higher production of protein
when we deliver the same rna via the
nanostructured lipid carrier compared to
the lipid nanoparticle so we think we
have a potent and thermostable delivery
vehicle
which we pair together with our
our rna replicon and together we think
that this is a
very important solution to the
rna vaccine problem and getting rna
vaccines to every corner of the globe
to every person who needs one this
technology right now
has completed its most of its
pre-clinical studies
it's working its way through toxicology
studies and we hope to start a phase 1
clinical trial
by quarter 4 of this year
i want to turn now to our potent vaccine
adjuvants
so by way of background many people may
know that adjuvants
are molecules that have been designed to
interact with the innate immune system
and their purpose is to increase the
immune response against an infectious
disease or a cancer
we've put adjuvants in vaccines for
close to 100 years
we first started putting heavy metals in
vaccines
at the beginning of the 1900s and
we recognized that by doing so these
heavy metals
caused an inflammatory response that
increased the efficacy of different
vaccines
but we're really in the golden age of
adjuvants now and i would say that
that's been heralded by the approval of
i would say one of the first modern
adjuvant formulations in 2017
and this is a system that includes a
toll-like receptor agonist
a tlr4 agonist known as mpl along with
other excipients and carrier molecules
and so
that first was included in the vaccine
shingrix
that took a vaccine for a that was
pre-ex
that previously vaccines for shingles
were about 50
effective and got less effective as you
got older and more vulnerable ironically
to shingles
but it took that vaccine and changed it
and
changed both the construct of the
vaccine and the adjuvant that was used
and in adding an adjuvant to a
glycoprotein vaccine that vaccine became
close to 98 effective including in
people over the age of 80.
so really that hurled at a new age of
adjuvants
and now we recognize that this
combination of a toll-like receptor
agonist
in different formulations allows for
highly potent vaccines
these these adjuvants can be
freeze-dried and stored at room
temperature for long periods of
time and what we know is that they allow
for the protection of vulnerable
populations through a number of
mechanisms
they allow for broader responses and
they allow for more durable responses
and i'll show you some data that's been
generated in the context of kovit and
these are data that are sort of hot off
the press
and now into pre-publication so first
here's a publication that you can see
the reference below
pre-publication again on bioarchive that
looks at the addition of an idria
adjuvant called 3m o52
alum that's been co-developed with 3m
this adjuvant when added to a sars cov2
rbd
ferritin nanoparticle leads to as you
can see here
about a one log higher titer of
neutralizing antibodies compared to
rna vaccines and you can see that it
does that both to the d614 g
sars cov2 variant as well as the b117
variant
on the right what you can see though is
very interestingly that the addition
of the adjuvant to the protein vaccine
leads to broad cross-strain protection
so
by adding the adjuvant you afford
protection against stars cov1 stars cov2
and two different strains of that
coronavirus so we're very encouraged by
this and we think that
the addition of a strong toll-like
receptor adjuvant
in this case atollic receptor 7-8
agonist
to a very good protein vaccine
could actually allow for cross-strain
protection
and more than that we think that this
protection will be durable
so this is also data that's been
pre-published now
again referenced below but what we've
compared is the use of
a similar adjuvant formulation this one
instead of with alum but with a
squarely a stable emulsion uh here s e
so 3m o5 2 se using that
that tlr-78 adjuvant
with a protein vaccine leads to
significantly higher
vac antibody titers both on the left you
can see total igg
and on the right you can see pseudovirus
neutralization titers
so higher than the rna vaccines and
non-human primates
but also as you can see on the uh on the
bottom right
that the duration of protection i mean
this is antibody titers as expressed by
ic50
really the the shape of the curve and
the decline in the curve as modeled out
with the blue uh line which is the
uh adjuvanted protein vaccine affords a
significantly longer protection
the time scale on the bottom is on the
farther most right time point of 72
weeks
so again modeling protection above that
that lower limit of protection for
you know about a year and a half and
that's
we think very impressive for um the
current state of
uh covid vaccines with the last few
moments i want to turn to something
that's completely different
that we're doing here at injury and so
what that is is we're also looking at
new ways to treat this infection
so we think that there are limitations
to current treatments for covid while
the
morbidity is certainly and the mortality
of covet has declined
what we are seeing is that of the
treatments that are currently
available we see a couple of limitations
one is that they may
may not have efficacy across all groups
of people
who are have covid19 disease what i mean
by that is that there are several
therapies that are most effective in
individuals with severe disease
or some in very early disease but few
for the full spectrum of patients
at the same time we worry that the
treatment of some of these
using some of these modalities may
render
patients more susceptible to future
covet infections by reducing immunity
to the virus in the context of treating
the acute infection
so we have lots of reasons to think that
natural killer cells which are an
important arm of the immune system
play a critical role in viral infections
what we know is that these cells traffic
to the lung
that they recognize virally infected
cells to become activated
that once they're activated they kill
the target cell but then they also
increa secrete interferon gamma and tnf
alpha
that allows the recruitment and priming
of t cells so while they both kill the
virus
and the virally infected cells they also
may help to establish a more effective
cytokine milieu
and in so doing lead to more effective
treatment and
future protection against the virus we
currently are
leading a phase one phase two
clinical trial uh of an nk cell product
known as sync01 that is produced by a
company in new jersey called cellularity
and what we're looking to investigate is
whether the treatment with sync01
leads to better clinical outcomes as
well as a number of translational
outcomes
in patients with moderate covid19
infection
so that trial is currently ongoing it's
a two-phase study with a phase one
portion that is
not randomized to look at safety and
tolerability
and a phase two portion that is
randomized to really look at efficacy
and here you can see some of the data
that we'll be presenting over the next
several weeks
um it's a little too small to to really
see well here but
of the first six participants that have
been treated to date we've seen
responses and five of those six
participants um and
of those participants they've cleared
their virus
they have had clinical improvements in
radiography over a very short time
period
as well as an assessment of clinical
benefit by their treating clinicians
so we're excited about this therapy
we're excited to complete this ongoing
clinical trial and we hope that this
will add to our overall knowledge
of how we deal with this pandemic most
excitingly these nk cells were off the
shelf
they are not specific to covid19 it
could be very useful for future pandemic
respiratory viral infections
so in summary what i'd like to end with
is are these conclusions
that we've made amazing progress um as a
as a scientific community in in speeding
several coveted vaccines through the
clinical development pipeline i mean to
think of a vaccine
going from initial conception to
emergency approval
or emergency use authorization in just
11 months
is nothing short of remarkable however
we still
the majority of the population around
the world and even here in the united
states
lack access to these vaccines and what
we need to do
is make sure that everyone around the
world has access to these technologies
and that they have access to
technologies that
are durable and have protect against a
broad range of viruses
so with that we hope that these tools
and technologies our thermostable rna
vaccines
our adjuvanted protein vaccines and even
some of these nk cell therapies
may lead to future successes against
this and other pandemic viruses
um our institute here in seattle uh
is we're 28 years old um we are a small
research institute but a potent one
with a budget of about 25 million
dollars in this fiscal year
we have about 65 employees almost all of
whom are in scientific roles
and we work on next generation vaccines
we work on global health solutions as
i've just described
and we have incredible manufacturing
capacities here in seattle that
serve as a resource for academic
nonprofit and startup biotech
around the world so with that i thank
you for your time and your attention
today
my contact information is here and i'm
always
excited and eager to talk to
collaborators around the world
about the work that we do here and the
work that all of you are doing
to help end this pandemic and prevent
future ones
thanks for your time today